la convocatoria de este miércoles la
protesta que vemos con la respuesta de
los organizadores y promotores de este
faro nacional a ese primer encuentro que
hubo con el presidente llevando que fue
un encuentro en el que no hubo ningún
acuerdo y en respuesta los promotores el
denominado comité del paro organizó esta
marcha a nivel nacional lo que vemos
aquí en bogotá avanza de manera masiva
esta mañana hablábamos con algunos
representantes de las centrales obreras
que también hacen parte de los que
promueven este faro nacional nos decían
que ellos no quieren volverse a sentar
con el gobierno cuando aquí no haya una
certeza de desmilitarizar las
principales ciudades del país ellos al
igual que muchas personas que vemos aquí
tienen como uno de sus principales ejes
en este momento de la protesta la
denuncia de los abusos policiales y es
que durante el día las manifestaciones
aquí en bogotá y en otras partes del
país transcurren de manera pacífica pero
es en la noche
hemos visto esos abusos y esas aparentes
abusos de derechos humanos y esas
denuncias de violencia policial desde la
policía ya se abrió una investigación se
abrieron 26 investigaciones por abusos
de autoridad 18 de ellas son por
homicidio